life can change in a fraction of a
second
[Music]
Carlos going with the best automotive
CEO in the world
one of the most respected business
Executives ahead of Bill Gates we have
reached a new era
it's kind of the story of Icarus a guy
soared to the highest of highs
probably too high
breaking news Carlos scone has been
arrested in Japan many serious
wrongdoings money laundering and
Corruption goon faces a maximum penalty
of 10 years imprisonment
is Carlos Cohn a victim or a villain
[Music]
I'm about to surprise you
there was tons of evidence there's hard
driving it's a key to the entire going
story
and calls and former Green Beret the
plan was to put him in a box and drill
holes so he could breathe
foreign
[Music]
life's got a lot of strange twists and
turns
foreign
[Applause]